Mike Scott tt help cover it good adjust  it was a bike former good defense that  time they've really covered for each  other Wells he had written rotation here  comes Jenny running the floor James with  the head up sixty points in the first  half that it's an offensive game LeBron  sends it right wings and buries it the  truth comes right back but the  penetrator was causing the switching and  the switching is what's causing the  mismatches under the board yeah great  point LeBron James in a fall away over  Mike Scott starts the second half LeBron  James doing a good job of measuring it  and get that weak stuff out of here John  Wall and he gave it up because of a  double team cats with a steep defense on  a superb  weendigo thanks God  fully aware license plate and an n-word  the boots good solid defense here though  they won't they won't give him the drive  to the basket they make him throw the  ball away and then they take off to the  races spindle